ah se sei in gesù per ora mi fai vince è
normale
ma figura perché hai smesso di parlare
lo è allora andiamo andiamo nella casa
quella destra
reja vedi lo posso guardare la juve è
vero enrico ammazzarlo vieni qua però a
cazzo non si gioca sta roba
se letti morphine location puoi andare
in una location legami che ha capisco un
sacco ciao asia mi chiama quindi tutti
poi teletrasportare in una location ma
mi chiama allora ma [ __ ] de puoi
farlo serve allora poi te ne stai no
dicono gara ti spacco la porta al
dialogo
tutto bene ti vengo a prendere anche la
famiglia pratica però aprirla con la
mano la porta ma io lo sfondo per loro
ma non corre e jason quindi dal camerino
e basta tale giorno lanciano chiusero al
neon accesi ma ok ma che cazzo elettrico
mitraglia ficcato una di quelle botte
imparare che cazzo ha ucciso l'uomo
invisibile con c'era uno che era
invisibile dello sfigato delle
coltellate morto primi tre dove la donna
ai pista che tipo badoche effigiata cosa
ho fatto
le scatole e stato bellissimo ecco come
facciano a vedere le cose vedo
attraverso i muri vedo un cerchio che si
illumina grazie al calcio e capisco
della gente
poi ovviamente io quando sono un
personaggio corno un minuto loro
la ferrari la prima fu seconda è aperta
e graziosi la vedo in streaming ma se il
pezzo di merda ma sarà estratto o la
benzina
basta manuali aiutare a vincere sei tu
quello che manca la tanica di benzina
quindi no cosa rispetto ti ammazzo
subito ciao fratello come stai aveni
perché sta tentando di colpirmi ma io
gli faccio un culo rame da base madonna
ma direi
ho visto dei sei ok 1 ci siamo che
figata
le palle per te è finito io roser luci
rarissimo no a zia incredibile dovessero
molto prima adesso sì che ho capito come
funziona jason che cazzo sei andato che
ricky che correvi tute nere maledetto
fuori cazzi tuoi
che cazzo ma lesbico messa messa la
macchina qua salve
la macchina non sarà caga nessuno o che
prima non mi sa di aver capito dove la
gente
ciao
siete qua e brutti stronzi india che vi
spacco la porta pace in culo c'è rumer
incredibile sete e trasportata dentro
casa di chiamato sta giocando con questa
salve salve signora come sta tutto a
posto
[Risate]
[Musica]
madonna che bello questo gioco anche se
un sacco la tua ecco allora la pula
tutta ma se non avevo mai capito io chi
c'è la barca è piuttosto strano perché
non si farà un affare che li mortacci
tua
se l'ultimo che rimane vivo scommetto e
maledetta dati lo stato ti ammazzo ti
ammazzo ti ammazzo a pezzo di merda uno
è scappato con la polizia ok come no
essi spesso si può evidentemente
scappare che la polizia solo anno e non
funziona siete rimasti in due zio quindi
vi spacco il culo
no non ci provare non ci provare eccoli
hectic la che carico da tanichetta non è
che la piccola che caricata a salve
mo giorno lo vendiamo ascolti ascolti
c'e questo tasto 4 che cos'è vediamo un
po
ehilà ei non facciamo forse già con
morgana che tipica di chi aspira a
ispica è lesbica a lesbica è la madonna
era per oggi cannavacciuolo il segnale è
cotto letto ed è pietra dai di vino 20
video è quello stronzo
allora è in mezzo alla foresta che sta
camminando dove sarà la cura e alla pura
e la pula mara mi sono io a finire
chiede eccoti qua
eccoti che hanno preso tale data tanto a
cantata da buongiorno andiamo a posto ti
piace questo gioco è bello sto gioco è
tornata oggi insegniamo a farli
cotolette di persone oggetto matera
la strada che cos'è
è bello 5 su 6 e per la prima volta
basta solo un [ __ ] però c'è un
peccato mica tutti insieme massacrati
vecchia a lesbica allora ragazzuoli
partiamo subito vicino alla macchina
vediamo cosa riusciamo a fare mancano
tanica batterie chiavi prego ai miei
compagni a quegli esseri inutili
chiamati anche compagni di aiutarmi
visto che sono in live bica non mi danno
ma in attesa è una donna mite anche
siamo partiti porca vacca ma stai calmo
guarda c'è qualcun altro cioè pepe ciao
peppe ogni quando smetti di giocare a
calcio viene i suoi nervi 13 bene
infatti ho le chiavi dato notte lui io
sento la musica di jazz ma non vedo
jason
eccolo beppe spara licei la pistola
spara gli sbagli peppe spara lì poi
crossa in mezzo nel dubbio mio calcio ho
la batteria al materiale fu regalato a
batteria fermi tutti fermi tutti e sua
batteria zitti come si parla qua quale
il tasto find the tanica de che io c'ho
la batteria avrà capito si avrà capito
sicuramente è belen come pepe uscito
dalla partita merda sono da solo spero
che se n'è andato jason gesone da moro
langa jason e da loro no cazzo c'è una
trappola per terra by liberty liberati
via libera tv da timo donna allora metti
subito la batteria subito bye bye bye
bye bye sion perfetto solo la tanica
ragazzo la tanica il play lo potevi
trovare una cazzo di david ragan porca
di tutti sono morti ice skate sono
scappati con la macchina si schifosi
ma [ __ ] lasciate voi che avete
trovato le taniche di mortacci vostri
bene su conte
aiuto aiuto sballo aggiunto sparla aiutò
il bagno in bagno eccolo vai vai vai
curati curati quasi a quello sta
sfondando ragazzi una tanica vi prego
gesù vi prego datemi una tanica ma
l'inizio è quanto tempo di una [ __ ]
dove il limite è la madonna e cazzo se
il cecchino e ha lanciato uno
stuzzicadenti
no è don't a cipro don't ask don't a
cipro dolciumi ai denuncio hayden you
fortissimo come qui hiking and youth mai
lamborghini evidenti mai lamborghini
della lamborghini no no that's brown
dance ma disi this is not of di un
rimorchio a girl this is not a visita ai
denuncia è sempre pezzo di merda è però
è bastardo
ma quanto ci fate che la tanica la trovo
in 0,3 secondi ma ve lo giuro che la
trovo in così poco ma sicuro
if you find the tanica della donna
faremo come corre subito subito find the
battery otis fucked a famiglia ovvero se
senti tornare in formula della mia
veloce ighalo m'incazzo a lesbico la
mappa l'ho trovata della fede di testa
di ca è ma toccato di pace ma yes and
non si fa solo una macchina in sto giro
minchia allora vado subito perché qua la
titanica non c'è nei media find this
fucking batteri please di cose am rotto
il cazzo è quadrato jason ha già
sfondato tutto oppure le loro madri
almeno le chiavi ragade porca vacca ma
avete controllato in giro o sto contando
solo io che qua tutto chiuso e find the
battery click aiuto aiuto ancora fatta
ma qua è da zero perché lo ha fatto
ma siccome è pieno di gente ma cosa vuoi
da me ma se pieno di gente ma robbie
caccia agli altri no porca [ __ ] maglia
mi ha via via via la fine sec difficoltà
finestra aperta vai vai vai veloce
calp mia ed è [ __ ] epex a mazzei da
porca vacca che porta poi mai nicchia
che donna una donna da sposare raga se
però sia de vico madonna molto quanto
lindt a questa donna
guardi i problemi quanto lenta ma perché
occorre ma io ci mostra che il
deodorante
porca vacca ha posto zio michele botta
furti almeno 200 uscire fate
dunque io dovrei capire come il bianco
l'accordo sulla macchina del caffè oggi
ossia il fucile usa lo è
usalo perché portava bravo bravo a
sparagli spagna bravo bravo così fargli
male
arriviamo al nord ma non venire tra sono
io ma lei altra parte cariparma kids
arrivata ma ora se sti stronzi non
ripara la mattina quando non ci sono io
ci metto un ora ma dormo ci vado con te
perilli o no acceso non seguire me non
seguire me per l'amore di gesù ma perché
segue me perché l'altro li aspetta la
donna che nervi o che nervi che merda ma
iv dell'altro uomo ha sparato addosso ma
a follower a rim test the cool
[Musica]